Welcome to the debate.
Today we open the final chapter of The Master and the Disciple to explore the profound assertion that the chain of just witnesses was never broken, only sometimes concealed.
The earth is never without a just witness from a law for the blink of an eye.
Does the scriptural mention of an interval between prophets imply a genuine suspension of divine guidance or merely a shift from public manifestation to tactical concealment?
In our discussion of this text, I will represent the position of the master, arguing for an unbroken, albeit concealed chain.
And I will represent the disciple, arguing that apparent historical silences indicate the chain has paused or severed.
The text, it forces a profound crisis of historical reality upon the seeker by acknowledging what we all eventually confront.
The Quran explicitly names intervals between prophets.
We look at the historical record, and we just do not see a seamless, unbroken tapestry of visible divine guides.
Instead, we see vast, silent spans of time.
Consider the immense chronological gulf between Abraham and Moses, or the deep, centuries-long silence stretching between Moses and Jesus.
I see the tension there.
If divine justice strictly requires that humanity is never left without a guide, how do we explain the apparent silence in our own age?
The student looks at the contemporary world, searches for the public manifestation of that guidance, and, well, sees a void.
Okay.
In an attempt to resolve this, the broader community has historically settled on two entirely failed answers.
The first is the school's reading, which interprets the scriptural intervals as real, literal absences of the witness.
They accept that divine guidance was simply withdrawn from the earth for centuries at a time, leaving humanity to navigate the darkness entirely on its own.
A very mechanical view.
Yes, a mechanical view, where the divine presence just exits the stage.
The second failed answer is the despairing reading.
This is the perspective that internalizes the current void as a permanent systemic failure.
I hear that.
The faithful look at the absence of a public profit, look at the suffering of the world, and conclude that humanity has been abandoned, that the continuous threat of revelation has been permanently severed.
Well, both the school's reading and the despairing reading collapse because they share the exact same fatal philosophical error.
They operate on the flawed assumption that if a witness is not publicly visible, the witness does not exist.
The master argues that this misinterprets the very nature of an interval.
I am listening.
The presence of the witness is constant.
Only the visibility changes.
To suggest that creation is arbitrarily abandoned to wander blindly for centuries contradicts the core premise of divine justice established much earlier in the book.
God does not build an intricate spiritual architecture for humanity only to occasionally tear it down or walk away from it.
The interval is not an empty space in the continuum of guidance.
The error lies in equating public manifestation with existence
The witness remains, the guidance remains, but the operational posture of that guidance shifts in response to the specific, often dangerous, conditions on the ground.
If we were to check the school's reading of literal absence and the despairing reading of a severed chain, we must demand concrete proof of this historical continuity.
And the teacher provides that proof by stripping away abstract theology and demanding we look at the actual historical sequencing.
He recites the chain by name to entirely refute the concept of an empty interval.
He directs the disciple to examine the specific period after Abraham.
I follow.
He notes that Allah sent after him Ishmael, Isaac, Jacob, Jonah, Shoaib, leading directly to Moses.
There is no void in that history.
And examine this span after Moses Allah sent Joshua, Elijah, David, Solomon, Saul, Zachariah, and John, leading directly up to Jesus.
The chain operates link by link with each prophet upholding the prior book until the next major book is sent down.
Think of it as a structural continuity.
A new major revelation is a massive architectural shift.
But between those shifts, the spiritual infrastructure does not collapse.
Sure.
Every single name in that sequence represents A continuous unbroken presence maintaining the plumbing of the faith.
They upheld the prayer, they gave charity, they maintained the legal and moral judgments of the prior revelation until a new one arrived.
The speaker then rereads chapter 5, verse 19, which mentions a messenger coming after a period of messengers.
Okay.
He introduces the term fatra.
He explains that this word does not denote an empty span of time, but specifically names a period of fear.
During such a time of intense persecution, the Dawa went secret, but was not absent.
The call to the divine moves from the public square into concealment.
Precisely.
It operates exactly like an underground resistance movement.
When a resistance faces overwhelming existential violence from an occupying force, it does not dissolve.
It goes dark, it protects its network, it communicates in secret, and it preserves its core mission until the environment allows for public action.
The commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, taught this exact concept centuries prior to this letter.
He noted that the proof is never withdrawn, only its visibility changes.
The earth is never without a just witness from Allah for the blink of an eye.
That underground resistance analogy breaks down.
I mean, when we look at the cost of that secrecy, if these witnesses are continuously present, what possibly justifies their total devastating concealment in our current time?
Go on.
The seeker looks at a world steeped in corruption, systemic suffering, and unchecked oppression.
If the chain is unbroken, and these guides exist specifically to establish justice and uphold the truth,
Hiding in the shadows looks exactly like an abdication of their very purpose.
I see the concern.
A hidden resistance movement that never emerges to fight the occupier is useless to the people being crushed by that occupier.
A hidden guide provides no visible direction, no legal clarity, and no protection to a community that is desperate for it.
When the master argues that the visibility changes, he ignores the reality on the ground.
complete and prolonged invisibility feels indistinguishable from absence to the people suffering.
It contradicts the very necessity of having a guide in the 1st place.
It only looks indistinguishable from absence until you analyze the brutal mechanics of survival and the preservation of the message itself.
The concealment is not an abdication.
It is a vital preservation strategy grounded deeply in scriptural precedent.
The teacher answers this challenge by pointing to Moses fleeing into Midian.
When Moses discovered that the chiefs of Pharaoh were taking counsel to slay him, he did not stand in the city square, puff out his chest, and invite martyrdom.
He fled the city fearful and vigilant to preserve his life and his mission.
If the messenger is destroyed before the message takes root, the entire divine project for that era is extinguished.
Concealment under threat is not a failure of the divine economy.
It is the divine economy operating as it must.
The prophet withdraws when the community becomes a mortal threat to the continuation of the message.
I followed logic.
To explain exactly why this threat persists so deeply in the world, the Master introduces 3 distinct categories of people regarding the hidden witnesses.
There is the relentless murderer, who actively hunts the guides down,
There is the deep-seated enemy who burns with ideological rage against them.
And finally, there is the sympathetic abandoner.
Okay.
The master makes a profound structural move here.
He places the operative moral weight entirely on the sympathetic abandoner.
This is the person who feels affection for the Friends of Allah, who dislikes the oppressive actions of the enemies, but who ultimately abandons the witnesses in practice and cannot be relied upon to protect their secret.
It is entirely because of this third category that the witnesses are forced into concealment.
For anyone engaging with this text, that distribution of blame sounds completely inverted.
How can the passive, sympathetic abandoner carry more moral weight and blame than the violent executioners or the oppressive rulers who are actually hunting the witnesses?
A fair question.
The relentless murderer is the one actively shedding blood.
The deep-seated enemy is the one organizing the persecution, funding the terror, and building the prisons.
The sympathetic abandoner is merely passive.
They are frightened bystanders.
They may lack the immense courage or the strategic insight required to stand up, but they are not the ones holding the sword or issuing the execution orders.
Placing the operative cause of the withdrawal of divine guidance on the shoulders of the passive bystander feels like a severe misdirection of justice.
It lets the true tyrant off the hook and absolves them of their primary role in severing the community from its guide.
That assumes violence operates in a vacuum, which ignores the actual structural mechanics of power and oppression.
The tyrant does not rule through personal physical strength alone.
A tyrant cannot personally enforce
his will on millions of people.
Okay.
The tyrant rules entirely through the compliance, the frictionlessness, and the legitimation provided by the broader community.
The scholar's pen sits much earlier in the causal chain than the executioner's hand.
I see.
Without the scholar legitimating the oppressor, the oppressive force completely collapses.
The master heavily indicts the legal scholars and community leaders who serve the oppressors, pointing out that those who blacken a flag or fill an inkwell for the murderers share directly in the bloodshed.
If the scholars did not pass legal opinions and moral justifications enabling the oppressors, those oppressors could not maintain their psychological and societal dominion over the populace.
The tyrant needs a facade of legitimacy to keep the masses docile.
To prove how central this mechanism is, the master cites chapter 11, verse 113, which commands believers not to incline toward those who do wrong.
Inclining toward them isn't about actively committing murder.
It is about providing the societal stability that allows the wrongdoer to operate without resistance.
He cites chapter 4, verse 59, concerning the proper obedience to authority
illustrating how the community willfully misapplied obedience to the very illegitimate rulers they were commanded to struggle against.
And he cites chapter 9, verse 123 regarding the duty to fight those who reject the truth.
Failing to push back allows the rejection of truth to become the baseline status quo.
I hear that.
The scholars who serve the state are fundamentally worse than the murderers because they construct the ideological architecture that makes the murder acceptable to the public.
The prophet peace and blessings upon him and his family taught that the best struggle is a word of justice against an oppressor.
When the sympathetic abandoners fail to speak that word, when they participate in the systemic legitimation of tyranny just to maintain their own comfort, they create the very societal conditions that make hiddenness A moral necessity.
The witnesses hide because the community has structurally alight itself with the murderers.
If the community is this deeply complicit and the witnesses are forced into complete hiding by our own structural failures, we are trapped in an irreversible state of spiritual deprivation.
The disciple realizes that society is entirely held together by this vast network of complicity.
It is not just one bad ruler.
Every institution, every scholar who complies to keep their position, every passive bystander who pays their taxes and looks away forms an impenetrable interlocking wall between the community and the hidden guide.
I understand.
If the absolute condition for the guide's return is the dismantling of this massive, entrenched, societal architecture of legitimation, the task appears mathematically impossible.
The seeker is left staring at a global system designed from the ground up to keep the witness concealed.
We are entirely crushed under the weight of our own historical and ongoing abandonment.
The book offers a precise path of return for those who recognize their complicity.
If you were all to help the Friends of Allah, they would reveal themselves.
And if you were to abandon their enemies, they would not be victorious.
Seek protection with Him, and He will give you refuge.
Turn to Him in repentance and He will accept it.
Ask Him for the path of His friends and He will rescue you through your own righteous actions.
For Allah does not do an atom's weight of wrong and does not hasten to punish even those who hasten to disobey Him.
He loves those who turn to Him in repentance.
When you lay bare the mechanics of our societal architecture like that, I have to concede that the text's diagnosis of our structural failure is exact.
The student recognizes that this framework of complicity, the passive abandonment, the inquell filled for the oppressor, perfectly describes the current state of her community.
As the seeker, she repents.
The realization that the concealment is not a random divine punishment, but a direct, reversible consequence of our own collective actions completely changes the theological landscape.
It shifts the burden of action entirely.
It moves the believer from passively demanding that the hidden guide appear to realizing that the community must actively dismantle the legitimation of tyranny to create the conditions that make appearance possible.
Yes.
This transformation in understanding is brilliantly captured in the book's closing seal, honoring the trustee, the father of imams, acknowledging the continuous, unbroken flow of guidance passed from scholar to disciple, preserving the profound truth until the community is
actually ready to receive it openly.
The earth is never without a just witness from Allah for the blink of an eye.
Which of the three categories are you, and what one act of help or abandonment this week will move you out of the third?